it is a pleasure to have this man right
here in studio and even more of a
pleasure
at the same time to get his remarkable
and fantastic and perfect show curb your
enthusiasm back on television season 11
of curb your enthusiasm premieres this
sunday october 24th at 10 40 p.m eastern
time everybody synchronize your watches
on hbo good to see you once again
larry david how are you larry 10 40.
yeah it is
really did you not know that am i
informing you of that decision i i
thought it was 10 30. it is i was told
it is 10 40 p.m eastern they get 10 40 i
don't know is there like a show in front
of yours
i have no idea
wait what's on what's on at uh 10
o'clock or i don't know i got to check
my local listings on that but
whatever good to see you larry how are
you so great to see you rich did we have
you back here in this studio this is
quite a uh quite a man cake thank you
thank you we've cultivated this caper
for about seven plus years so
uh did you add to it by yourself did you
uh
did you contribute ideas as to what you
wanted well um actually the person who
contributes the ideas is my wife a lot
of the stuff that you see here larry is
get this out of the house
that looks good in your studio you get
the high reps you know you know what
that'll look good your studio though
really yeah i got that oh yeah my wife
does that quite a bit you got up you got
a place for your junk that's yeah pretty
much i got storage every single day
is she a sports girl oh sure susie you
know sits in here as a matter of fact
she's got a sign that's right here when
she sits in here i've got the best dad
ever signed i got a best mom son right
over here but so yeah everything's going
good uh so look great to see you here um
just to start off our conversation um i
would like to make you the commissioner
of the nfl okay okay and i want larry
larry david you are now
the new commissioner of the national
family yes congratulations are you
kidding there you go congratulations
this is a dream okay
i could curb your enthusiasm in a second
if this is true okay okay so now let's
let's uh how does your how do you wave a
wand what do you do first as the
commissioner of the national football
league larry david number one mm-hmm and
i really don't care if people like it or
not
i'm losing the goal post wait what
why why are there goal posts okay why
why are kickers um okay who have
they don't have football skills they
they're not football players i'm sure
they're wonderful people but they're not
football players why why why are they
kicking a ball through goal pose to
decide games
it doesn't make any sense at all it's a
first of all goal posts are a relic from
the old english rugby i think okay you
know when they used to actually run and
kick a ball through goal post but they
don't do that in the nfl
there's no need for goal posts
what wouldn't the game be better without
them think about it why not just have
leaping frogs to decide games
have a zebras diva frog
a little goal post that you set up okay
on the floor and if the if the frog can
leap through the goal pose then then do
that what why kick it through a goal
post well it's not called leaping frog
ball it's called
football so you're saying take the feet
out of footballs is that what you're
saying larry is that what you're saying
yes why feet are deciding games and they
shouldn't why should one player
one player with this skill like the guy
on the ravens mm-hmm justin tucker yeah
why should this one player who does
nothing but kick a ball
be deciding games when you have
uh how how many people on a football
team eleven or 53 53 man roswell
52 other players who are actually
playing and this one person this 53rd
person is deciding games
it it makes no sense whatsoever
maybe yes after i got rid of the gold
post
okay that's so that's we're checked off
that one on the first lesson that's
number one goal posts out larry david
nfl commissioner no more goal posts i
don't say nobody can make an argument
for for field goals and even extra
points there's no argument for it so
you're going forward on fourth down
every time that's what it goes every
time every time uh-huh yes okay
if you're on if you're on the other
team's 30-yard line yes you know you've
got four downs to get a first down right
you're not playing for a field goal
you're playing to score a touchdown and
let me tell you something yes larry
when you score the touchdown yeah okay
yes you will you'll be the winner yeah
and you'll you'll be the deserving
winner
they won't say oh the kick listed by
this now you'll score a touchdown the
old-fashioned way the way it's supposed
to that's how you get points this field
goal kicking i can't stand it
cannot stand it so then you have to go
for two right is there or is there no
conversions at all
okay that's next coming next okay yes no
there are conversions okay from the
one-yard line you choose to do it it's
one point
from the two-yard line
it's two points yes
i might think about it yeah
might give you i might give you three
points from the uh six or seven yard
line okay all right so if so if you're
down if you're down like eight yeah okay
and you score a touchdown you could you
could either go from two to tie yes or
six-ish possibly maybe
six to ten how far back do we go for how
many points larry no that's it i stopped
at three
that's it that's it okay
and by the way so we do this for a
couple of years
and if i'm still around if i'm still a
commissioner
and i know people are really gonna like
this rule it's gonna change the game for
the better yeah and you cannot present
any arguments that this is this is wrong
okay yes it's gonna change the game for
the better
and then
i might get rid of the punter
so you give the punter a grace period to
find all their work yeah yeah you put
them on now so you're putting punters on
notice the minute you're becoming the
question
it's something i'm going to think about
okay okay yes i'm going to see how my uh
my other rule goes with the no feel go
take down the goal post for sure they
used to have them out in the actual end
zone i know no they used to have them in
at the goal line yeah right yeah i used
to have him right there and players
would crash into it right yeah
oh come on so no no no
no kicking this is a good rule two point
conversion from the two one point
conversion from the one yeah three-point
conversion from the six-ish seven
you'll put that in the committee yeah
they'll come out right that's in the
committee yeah and then punters put on
notice on the spot
that's that's i
might get rid of the punter so
if you get the ball then i would change
it to getting the ball
after a touchdown
you'd be getting the ball maybe on the
35 okay so we're not we're start we're
starting at the 35 yeah no more kickoffs
no more kickoffs no kickoffs yeah no
more you don't like the returns the
kickoff returns you don't like that well
there's even there's no more returns
anymore they all kick it over the over
the goal line what if you would you give
the field the kicker points
for actually getting it through the
upright on the kickoff larry david would
you do that no okay what do you think
i'm still giving this person with this
one skill yes uh an impact in the game
they're out they're just done they're
done okay commissioner larry david of
the nfl has spoken yeah what do you like
do you like uh overtime rules do you
like the overtime rules the overtime
rules are so ridiculous okay
so i win a coin toss yes okay and i
score a touchdown yes
and the other team
they're done yes right no good
why do they not have a chance so now a
coin toss
is deciding the winner of a game nothing
makes sense in this world i need i i i
need to be president not just nfl
commissioner
i would actually sign for that
no the coin toss is so idiotic i mean
it's not idiotic give the other team a
chance um
i agree give the other team a chance to
come back i agree exactly one team's not
fair it's just not fair let's do what's
fair
it's not fair
that
a kick goes through an upright by an
inch and they win a game because of this
skill
it's not fair larry david here on the
rich eisen show in studio again curb
your enthusiasm returns to hbo sunday
night um at says here 10 40 p.m eastern
time synchronize your watches for
episode number one and we'll talk about
that uh i do want to ask you about your
uh play callings i'm sorry what are you
guys i know what you're gonna ask me
about my play calling yeah i'm playing
your play calling skills i want to ask
you about your play calling
okay well first of all yes um
defensively yes i see i see things that
really disturb me that is
why is it
it hasn't even said anything yet
and i can't believe i'm the only person
who's brought this up okay
you have a running back yes okay yes the
quarterback drops back to pass
the running back kind of fades off to
the side
there's nobody up and down field because
three linebackers have dropped back in a
zone but here's this other guy
this running back
with this talent and this skill to catch
a ball and run with it nobody's guarding
him
he gets a little
seven-yard pass and boom he's off right
and he gains
i don't know four to ten yards every
time they throw him a little pass and
nobody guards him because there's three
linebackers back in a zone
looking at the quarterback's eyes
by the time he throws it to the running
back they're 20 yards away from him
so how do you fix this
here's how you fix it yes one of those
linebackers
is assigned to the running back
rush the running back
take the running back
like sack the running back is it really
not sack him but guard him
if if he's in the backfield go to the
backfield to guard him yes if he's off
to the side guard him
forget what you're doing in your zone
where you go where you're not guarding
anybody by the way i know nothing about
footballers
[Laughter]
these are just these are just little
observations
why are these running backs constantly
gaining yards from passing because
they're afraid i guess of the receivers
that were also in the route from going
downfield and you're trying to confuse
the quarterback defensive backs guarding
the receivers and yes two are the
linebackers to guard them as well
okay so the running backs are constantly
open so that's your defense it's so
disturbing to me
every time i see it
i can't believe it what's your offensive
wrinkle you came on my podcast back in
the day when it was an nfl network
before i was in this studio yeah um
where you came up with the double flick
the idea of a second flick of a flea
flicker you know when i was in the
playground i i would make up a lot of
good plays sure so if i get could you
give me
would you be able to give
an nfl team a good 15
scripted to start a game larry could you
really do that really you think so
not now what do you mean i would need
i would need to
i would need to study it okay i would
need to um
you know go down on the field
i would need to just talk to the
offensive coordinator
i would need to take a little course on
it
and then there's no doubt in my mind
then i could do it
no i have no doubts that i could do it
i'm completely confident after you i
just can't decide if i'd be a better
offensive coordinator or defensive
coordinator i think offensive it's a
little more creative okay yeah sure so
you can
what would you be would you be a passing
offense a running offense what would you
be what would you be
larry
we're getting we're getting really deep
into the weeds larry
i'm just trying to see like are you are
you more of the aerial attack guy you
want to grind it out i mean what no i
think i'd be a lot of trickery
yeah
there'd be a lot of trickery playground
style
not a trickery a lot of tricks i would
have here's what i would be doing yes
i would be setting up the defense
can i stand up here please go ahead
really you might be a little off mike
but we can trigger figure it out go
ahead okay yeah go no
i'm starting to feel like i'm insane
but good you got to set up the defense
for example yeah i saw a play last week
and i i forgot what the game was
but at the end
um
he
he went
he waited for the pass okay yeah
and the past uh he got the pass and he
gained a couple of yards
i'd be setting up defensive backs all
the time
like
okay i'm going like this and now i'm
coming back for the pass okay
so i would do that a couple of times and
then the third time i would go like this
i think i'd go and then do that
zoom down
and so that place called the the the
zoom the zoom down play that would be a
zoom down yeah
so like double triple quadruple moves
yes setting setting them up
setting them up i just setting up
everybody that's that's how i would
that's how i would plan my offense
setting them up
acting a lot of acting has to go on
the ends and the you know the receivers
they have to act
yes and so they have to be good at a lot
of decoys you need to do a lot of decoys
but pretending that this is the play oh
and being disappointed
being disappointed that they they didn't
get the ball you know
i would i say come back to the huddle
and start start going like that and
they'll think i'm giving you the ball
next time they'll be watching you right
yeah a lot of decoys a lot of setups a
lot of smoke and mirrors yes and then at
some point there has to be a play that
actually
works it didn't be many places to work
they're being set up all over the place
they're not even going to know what's
going on they're going to be so confused
come on sounds good right
it sounds good you're hard sounds good
larry i'm about by the way i'm available
larry david here on the rich eisen show
i'm available robert sala
there you go we've come up with this
this photograph for you right there with
your head set on
the oc
you got the play
sheet which you got to hold up because
they can't you don't want to read your
lips yeah yeah no
yes i do this in life now you know
i talk to people like this hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here